Jordan Henson thanks so much for joining
us it's um a real pleasure genuinely to
meet you thank you um and behind us
we've got these kids
playing football you're sponsoring this
program to get more kids to play
football 30 000 kids involved are you
concerned uh the kids aren't getting
enough exercise or that their parents
can't pay for exercise classes I think
in the world we're living at the minute
you know cost of living is becoming an
issue of course so to put on free
sessions for kids kids aged 5 to 11 I
think is really really important you
know just to get them outside running
about playing meeting new friends being
in a team environment and things that I
think football can give so much
especially when you're young I mean the
smiles that it puts on the kids faces
and I think it's um I think it's really
special with with what this this scheme
is yeah and just in terms of kids I was
looking into it in terms of kids and
exercise and childhood obesity is on the
rise recent statistics showed that
overweight or obesity uh in year six so
by the time kids are 10 to 11 it's 34 of
children that that's quite a lot isn't
it that sounds a lot yeah
um so yeah again when I was a kid you
know you didn't have so many computer
games or social media on the phone
things that I think that's obviously
evolved as time's gone on and a lot more
kids like to stay in the house play on
computer games and stuff which has been
which has been the case for a long time
but I think it just increases but I
think stuff like this is amazing you
know to get kids out get them playing
get them enjoying it
um and football is such a big part of
this country and a big part of Liverpool
big part of Liverpool here definitely a
big part of society here so
um I think it's important just to come
and make sure the kids are enjoying it
and
you are
quite unusual in the football Community
there's in the sort of amount of charity
work and work for the community that you
do I'm sort of thinking Marcus rashford
obviously is really known for the free
school Mills program so he's dealing
with kids that aren't getting enough
food and he launched that campaign it
made him a hero national hero but it
also made him a Target and I was
wondering with the work you do you've
got this massive platform and you can do
this and promote healthy living for kids
and football but it's not risk-free for
you sometimes
is there sometimes a bit of Jeopardy for
you in going beyond the job going beyond
the football pitch if you like to do
charity work or or to promote causes or
do you just think
I'm a privileged guy
I've got this great platform and I
should just do it well that's it exactly
really I'm not really bothered about
what people think I'm in a position a
privileged position where I can help
people and if I'm passionate about
something
then I'll do it you know things like
this for kids you mentioned Marcus who's
done amazing work and off the pitch as
well I think that's really important I
think
people look at footballers as if we're
not human beings but you know when we
were kids and the struggles that we've
seen for us to be able to give back is
you know give me great pride to be able
to come here and it's an honor to be
able to try and give back to the
community not only at Liverpool but
where I'm from in Sunderland as well
yeah you so you sort of feel you have a
responsibility to do it yes yeah
definitely definitely I think I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be where I am to deal with
without the the work ethic and the
things that were instilled in as a kid
from Sunderland so to be able to give
back there is is really important to me
but also Liverpool as well I know how
big football and how passionate they are
about football here and they've given an
awful lot to me and to the team and so
again it's it's a no-brainer for me to
be able to try and help kids and people
in this area and your dad was a
policeman wasn't he and uh so did he
sort of have this sort of sense of
public service and you think you that's
the values you grew up with
uh maybe maybe I haven't really thought
about that too much I just think it's
the right thing to do ultimately
um if I'm in a position where I can help
other people
um then I don't see a reason why I
shouldn't just because people might see
one or two things and for me it's about
just doing what I think is right and
trying to help as much as possible and
you um
now you're very true you're clearly
clearly in shape and you're still at the
top of your game in terms of football
but is this is the charity work you're
doing do you see it at some point as a
bridge into a post Jordan Henson
football world like this might be the
sort of stuff you might do in the future
you absolutely nowhere near that point
yeah I think charity work is something
that I've always tried to do behind the
scenes and always want to be involved in
and I hope that will continue right
while I'm playing and obviously when I
finish I'll always continue to give back
because I feel the responsibility and I
feel like I need to really and it's
important for me to do that so yeah
definitely I'll just carry on as long as
possible but I think everyone watching
this sort of Liverpool football fans and
England football fans will want you to
be carrying on on the pitch for a little
while yeah so let's talk a little bit if
we can about your football career you're
the Liverpool Captain yeah let's just
all pause there take that in uh you're
an England player you you've won the
Champion League the Premier League title
the UEFA super cup what is the dream for
you like what you do next is it a wild
can't win I mean the Euro finals must
have hurt like what's the next goal for
you professionally it never stops really
um you think that because you win
trophies that that's your dream and you
sort of wonder where you're going to go
from there but actually
it makes you more hungry for more to be
honest
um so every competition that I'm
involved in whether it's Liverpool or
England I want to win
and I give absolutely everything to try
me best to help the team achieve that
but you you have been at this for a long
time you were in the Sunderland Academy
when you were just eight years old like
a little tot you made your first team
debut a decade later you signed for
Liverpool in 2011 you became Captain did
you think when you were like the
eight-year-old you did you imagine
that you could do this that this was
where your destiny would be or did it
just sort of I think it obviously
evolves over time but I've always I've
always dreamed about being a footballer
I've always dreamed about
representing the country I've always
dreamed about winning Premier League
champions league so I've always dreamed
about them things but you know I'm sure
there's plenty of kids that dream about
that at a very young age and I've been
very fortunate and lucky enough to work
with a lot of good people have good
people around us and um and have the
attitude and the desire that want to go
and Achieve me dreams and yeah luckily
I've I've been able to do that and
hopefully I can continue doing that but
it wasn't
I mean the thing is it's it wasn't
always
with that adversity was it I mean no
one's career ever is is it I mean in
your younger days you were really tested
in the expectation of Liverpool when you
first joining you're a pretty young man
at that point weren't you and I think
after a year of signing you they nearly
sold you or they wanted to sell you to
Fulham that must have been was like
really difficult for you was that like a
at the time at the time it was a
difficult moment in my career I spoke
about it a few times so at the time you
know a young player coming into
Liverpool that was it was a difficult
period but looking back
it was an important period for me
developing as a as a person and made a
stronger and and actually I wouldn't
change I wouldn't change that path at
all I felt as though that time really
did make it was a lot stronger mentally
um and it's helped us do with a lot more
going forward Phil resilience do you
think it made you more empathetic well
like I've noticed that you are
social media like you're quite
people's mental health issues or being
different and feeling excluded either
thinking about
um that tweet you did after that
non-binary fan posted about feeling
scared about going into games they were
wearing makeup and you were really kind
about that do you think
that that is linked back to some of the
things you struggled with when you were
younger
I think yeah I think in the stuff that
I've I've done in the past of our mental
health and things like that definitely
is something that
um when I look back
um I experience difficult times and I
think when you're playing at the level
that that I am you're gonna go through
tough times
um and the pressure is high but that's
the world we're living and it's about
how you deal with that the processes and
I was again I was lucky enough to have
really good people around us
um and like and and again with the with
the tweet and things that either for me
it's about doing the right things and
um and trying to help people and make
people feel comfortable because at the
end of the day football is for everyone
yeah and you should feel comfortable
wanting to go to watch a football game
or wanted to come to a coaching session
whatever it may be everybody should feel
comfortable doing that but it's
important because if people like you
don't point that out
then a lot of people feel excluded but
it can put a Target on your back
sometimes but you're prepared to do that
yeah because again it's the right thing
to do in my mind in order to try and
help people because I don't think it's
right that people are uncomfortable
going to a football game at all
um so if I can help in any small way
then I feel a responsibility that that I
need to do that and I won't dwell on
this but just in terms of the pressure
which I cannot begin to imagine what the
pressure must be playing Top Flight not
just National but International Football
you must have been very pleased about
the draw against England against Germany
that was exactly what they needed are
yeah I was a little bit disappointed
because I felt we were so close to
winning the game in the end but I think
that was a snapshot
in terms of how the mentality of the
team I think they've had a lot of
criticism
um over the last couple of camps and
performances and results that were we
haven't had
um or what that we've had um hasn't been
great and we know that as a team and and
you've got to go through tough times
um and I think I've experienced that
over my career you know these tough
times can actually meet you go one way
or the other yeah in um NFL as though
last night was was a big moment for us
as a team in terms of the mentality I
think two nil down against Germany you
know it can go it can go
um a couple one or two years and I felt
it was all were responded really well
come back into the game and and probably
should have won it in the end you're a
leader you're a leader on the pitch
you're a leader in your community and
with klopp and Southgate you also work
with two exceptional leaders what do you
try to emulate uh from both of them like
what's the thing that you you may stood
more about them or the thing that you
try and harness for yourself in your own
game or in how you live even I think
you're right I think leadership is
something that has got to be natural but
you can also improve and develop that as
well and I've been so lucky again to
work with so many big personalities big
leaders players managers All of Me
career which has helped me and Jurgen
and Gareth probably complete completely
opposite people I would see it totally
different but have different qualities
in what way just
um
I just think they're just totally
different are they yeah just totally
different in terms of the way the work
and the way they do things
um and for me personally obviously I've
got a lot to thank them for yeah um but
especially Jurgen since he came here and
what he's done for me is a player
um and as a captain really and as a
person you know I think he's helped us
develop so much on and off the field
um
and he's been a huge part in me
development over the last five years or
so why can you give me some of how
they're different though just like I
just think that they're just in terms of
leadership I think leadership can come
in so many different forms
someone who will Who you'll follow and
he's very much uh
um charismatic yeah charismatic and you
believe everything he says he's very
um
speaks very well in front of the the
group and knows exactly what he wants
and we all follow
um whereas the whereas on the other hand
I feel as though Gareth
um has a different way about him and
will involve probably players a lot more
and have get their opinions and see how
they want to go about different things
and it has a different way of of working
and the both work and so it's it's
fortunate enough for me to be able to
see because you can learn from different
styles yeah that is really interesting I
wanted to ask you about the pandemic
because you set up the money for the NHS
during covid the players together
campaign it raised 4 million at launch I
don't know how much it ended up raising
um
it was an incredible thing to do
the then Health secretary Matt Hancock
I'm sure you saw it said around that
time that footballers should take a pay
cut and play their part right and you
did you I don't want to get really into
politics here but
um Darry Neville said yesterday that's
what inspired him to get into politics
like did you think that's a bit of a
cheap shot from Hancock or were you just
like I'm doing my thing don't care what
you say
yeah it was it was a cheap shot I'm sure
I don't know why what the reason was
whether or not he wanted to deflect away
from the pressure that he was under or
whatever but again for us it wasn't
we're already in in the process of doing
stuff
um and yeah we felt a responsibility as
a group of players across the league
that were in a privileged position again
we can really help and um and we all got
together all the captains got together
raised a lot of money there wasn't a
figured out Lies by you yeah well us I
would say we definitely gonna of course
I was involved in that but
um yeah I raised a lot of money we
didn't put the figures out there because
again
it was four million at launch presumably
it's a lot more than that at the end but
you don't want to say yeah we didn't
want to put a figure we didn't want to
tell me now now it's past no because we
never we never did and we never we never
wanted that to happen because we didn't
want that we didn't we thought it would
never it would never be enough really
and we didn't want people to know what
it was because I think no matter how
much careers there wasn't so much about
that it was about everybody coming
together to support people who really
needed at that time and the money went a
really good causes and we just felt as
though it wasn't right to put out the
figure do you sort of feel like you you
sort of ramped up the NHS fund do you
feel like that in terms of I need a lot
of charity work that the cost of living
crisis is something that you feel that
is an area that you're going to want to
kind of lean into or do more work with
in the next couple of years if I if I
can help definitely you know if this if
this area is that I can that I feel as
that I can help with then I'll do it and
I've got a obviously nor the information
and be really passionate about it but if
that's something that I need to help
with I know I know LFC Foundation do a
lot of work in the
um in Liverpool with with cost of living
and families and things like that which
is really good
um Olivia you put her name on your shirt
when you
played a match
against Bournemouth how do you think
what's happened to Olivia and her
family's affected Liverpool
I think it affected everybody in the
city really I think you know I can
remember my wife telling us the story I
didn't hear it she taught us and it
really
um struck a chord really you know I see
me just my eldest daughter
and I couldn't imagine the pain that the
family must be going through
um
so yeah
so difficult which is which is why I
felt I needed to to put a message on the
game because it was so close to the game
it was a little thing I know but yeah
everybody was hurting and um
it was a really tough time for the
family and like I said I couldn't
imagine that the pain that they're going
through and just in terms of what's
Happening Now your dad obviously was a
policeman the police can't find who did
it
yeah again that must be so difficult for
the family
um but in the end I hope they can and
and I hope that they do
um because I'm sure that's what the
family won but it's such a sad thing to
happen such a young age taking far too
early
um
and um yeah it's it was a it was it was
a dig straight record went out when I
heard the news I'm sure that um your
what you did also
comforted a lot of people who were
really struggling with it at the time so
I'm sure that I know you said it was
just a small gesture but
it probably made a difference to people
so anyway thank you so much I really
enjoyed talking to you thank you very
much really good thank you